[Music]
this is kind of the
uh go to uh
uh go to mental image of machine
learning
but in fact when we think about what
happens in
uh reality oftentimes the goal of the
model
isn't to label or classify or re or
regress it's rather to select a subset
of items
uh from a large collection so when you
think about for example personalization
if you have uh say something like uh
okay i'm trying to move some windows
around
okay so if you have something like a
personalization on your website
and you have a large collection of items
you might want to recommend to
some let's say web visitor uh then
the goal of the model is actually to
select a small set of items and maybe
rank them
and that's a very different kind of
problem in general and
it it uh it lends itself to very
different challenges both scientific and
engineering-wise
so if you look at image retrieval
saying in pinterest when you search for
images that contain some
several like similar garments or similar
styles when you do face
search this is that kind of
uh machine learning application where
you're searching
through a very large collection of
images with other images
both google and microsoft showed that uh
actually wrote extensive blog posts
about
how the retrieval of top searches
now for long questions or long-form
queries
is uh done better now with language
models and
deep learning retrieval uh solutions
uh and in personalization and shopping
this is very common when you're
having when you're doing say vacation
rental recommendations on some
somewhere like airbnb or when you're
doing shopping recommendation
uh anywhere online in retail
those are problems like that in fact i
would argue that
in terms of um
real impact on the world and how we use
and consume machine learning not
as practitioners and scientists but
engineers but rather as
as consumers of the technology almost
always when we interact with machine
learning and
we interact with machine learning of
this type
all of recommendation engines all of
visual visual search semantics search on
and bots now become even more common
uh but a lot of things behind the scenes
like
on uh fraud detection online advertising
um and so on all work in that way
and so it's it's an incredibly pro
important problem to solve and
and help companies iterate faster and
improve on
so uh the uh the different problems that
we talked about or the different
applications that we talked about used
to
use bespoke systems but we see now that
there is
a uh there is a unifying
uh deep learning model that kind of it's
not it's like a
it's like an archetype of a model it
isn't like a specific model
but a concept that seems to prevail in
almost all applications in taking
a lot of these traditional applications
and really transforming them to work
with deep learning and the way you do it
is
uh you take your query which could be a
person on your visiting a website or an
image
or a a query a textual quota or whatever
it is your query is
uh and you transform it into some dense
vector dense stencil
with some deep learning model or some
other
embedding solution you do the the same
thing
to your items in your catalogue again
being images or
items in your shopping catalog or
articles on on your media website
you transform those two into images
sorry into vectors or tensors and then
you
pairwise score them using yet a third
uh deep learning network and that gives
you a score of how good
this item is for this query now the way
you
uh select those items the way you select
what to show
are just the top scoring items so that's
a very similar
kind of naive solution so as an example
if i look at the big matrix of
many queries or mini potentially visible
to my website and many
for example items i can recommend in my
shopping cart
then for you know if i knew the score
for everything in this matrix
then i could uh easily uh give the
recommendations uh uh online all right
um and so just as
kind of to show you a few dif very
different applications that work this
way if you look at
early versions of image retrieval or
image similarity they went through some
common uh even pre-trained networks uh
like
alexnet or resnet or vgg or uh
uh inception and many many more i can
you know there's choose your favorite
and do some cosine similarity on that
that already gives you a pretty good
image similarity search engine
uh and again you can retrieve the top
most similar images
but you can do much more and much better
you can do much better if you transform
with the cnn and
then do pairwise scoring is and we see
new research showing that that
uh significantly outperforms uh
naive say embedding type solutions
uh the pinterest that i showed before
actually showed this
exactly what they do uh in you know they
publish the papers showing that
that's actually exactly what they do uh
on pinterest
if you're doing semantic similarity
search uh again
it's very common to try to do something
naive like transform
items with some language model encoder
like birth or any bi-directional or any
lstm type model
vector and just just a vector embedding
type solution
and do cosine similarity again that
already gives you some
interesting semantic search it might not
be the best thing
uh just because it's not very adaptive
to your data
but if you can train a pairwise score
and you can adapt
the transformers you actually get
top-notch results
and you that
already is is performing uh
giving you actually like top-notch
accuracy not only uh
kind of variety from your your
traditional search
uh and again there are many new results
that show
that uh these kinds of uh like three
network
solutions end up giving
extremely good accuracy an extremely
good
relevancy uh
to tie it up with a shopping
recommendation
it's you know if you can provide a
vector embedding
for each item in your shopping catalog
and if you can pro create a transform
solution that code that transforms a
shopping cart and maybe a shopping cart
plus a shopper
into another vector you can do some
similarity or some dot product search uh
over that space and recommend for a
shopper
in real time an item from the catalog
and again that provides
really good solutions uh nowadays much
better than traditional
uh uh traditional systems i'll show
something like that in
later uh for shopping they're like
we unfortunately don't have public
shopping data
but you can run the same thing on
something like movie recommenders for
which we do have public data
and we see that the same kind of
networks actually perform significantly
better than
uh traditional recommendation or or uh
traditional just simple embedding
solutions
so as scientists and engineers we think
to ourselves well we know how to train
those things to get
great solutions so i'm asking the
question are we done
and obviously we're not so if you listen
to zuniv stock
you know that only you know regardless
that
that's probably just the beginning of
your journey right
if you as a company are trying to
onboard
uh this solution you're actually just
starting this this is like this is just
the first baby step towards having
something in production
you really have to figure out how to do
training and experiments and tracking
and do that in a consistent
and reliable way
you have to create your applications to
be able to instrument and give you
feedback
uh you have to log everything correctly
and and
monitor that you have to create your own
data
prep and feature engineering and so on
and
most of all and all of these are very
difficult for ranking and retrieval
because data is big the the signal is
very sparse
but probably the hardest part of this is
having a serving engine or having
something in production
that lets you uh do all of this uh
at scale at uh in high speed because the
models are very complex and the number
of times you have to run them
is massive and it has all everything has
to be done in real time
so let's just kind of dive into real
time scoring for a second
uh and see what why that is difficult
again i'm focusing on one bullet out of
this entire slide
so if you think about uh a naive way to
do this
uh is i i have a pairwise nuance that
scores how good an item
is for my online chopper and so i should
just score everything in my catalog
and choose the two highest to ranking
items highest scoring items
well that kind of works if you have
roughly a thousand items in your catalog
and you have one query per second
uh you know if your model isn't too huge
you can just sweep over everything and
score everything every time there's a
query
not you know not very performant
but but probably fine
when you have more items in your catalog
about a hundred thousand
maybe 10 qps this is again a pretty
small
use case you're already in some
operational pain now you have to
evaluate your model about
a million times per second uh
that already doesn't cut it on a single
machine and definitely not with heavy
models
now you have to start distilling and
quantizing and compressing your network
so they operate faster
you have to do some uh maybe
parallelization to a few
machines and now you already have this
like two different models
they have to operate in lockstep and you
have some
what's called uh you have some
information loss so you have some
recall loss between one step and the
other because the distilled model could
have
potentially pruned away a good solution
for
one of the top scoring items uh well
that doesn't
quite cut it after you grow more if you
have about 10 million items and about
100 qps
now we're talking about some
like uh service and production again not
uh
not google or microsoft scale but
definitely at the retail
scale now you're already using
uh even further more efficient pruning
and now you have to create these
embeddings and maybe nearest neighbor
search or something else that prunes
away
even more aggressively and more up front
before you
you create your this you hit it with
your distilled model
and you have further recall laws on that
step
and further you have uh
you now have to basically create three
different machine learning solutions
that all work
in lockstep for this to be useful and
when you grow even more even that
doesn't cut it anymore so now when you
you're really at the billionaire it
actually happens in the hundreds of
millions already
and maybe even at lower qps than a
thousand
but just to keep the numbers around here
we're looking at a trillion model
valuations per second
uh at least theoretically if you did
brute force which of course you can't
uh and so here even nearest neighbor
solutions
kind of uh can't really work anymore
uh and you'll go you're going into
hardcore pruning or hard
like database search engine type pruning
where you're basically
like filtering on shopping uh
categories or buy some geo or some time
span or something
uh some some uh hard rule
that already prunes away good chunks of
your search space
uh needless to say that has a lot of
recall laws so now you really
are up front uh giving up a lot of great
candidates just because you really are
uh you just can't handle the the load
um and so uh this was
literally just like one step out of this
entire slide
where when you're growing and scaling
your application
in production as a company you might be
almost excited
or at least uh cautiously excited about
building great models
but very few companies that i'm working
with and talking with
are very excited about building this
like massively distributed
systems and being and wanting to support
them in production
so uh we we still have as a community a
lot to
uh improve and and deliver on
uh let me tell you a little bit about
how we're thinking about this
at hypercube so we've assembled an uh
an incredibly talented set of people
uh and what we wanted to see is how can
we improve this
and make this journey significantly
simpler easier and better for companies
all around and we we went
back to the basics and said wait a
second let's look at real time surfing
which you identify it as
a real problem right uh and see
how simple can we make this what is what
is
if i could just wave a wand and make all
the
problems go away and make the simplest
possible solution
how would that look like to the customer
and what we came up with
was basic basically i as a customer
don't want to do any of the building i
don't
want to do any of the the fancy systems
work
and i don't want to really know too much
about how to prune or do any of those
things i really want to
create a pairwise scoring function uh
that tells me how good one query is for
one search result
and that's it that's all i want to do
and i want everything else to be done
for me
and i wanted to scale and be performant
uh
and so uh in the beginning i thought
that would be impossible but we kept
thinking about we kept experimenting
with different solutions
and uh we now have something that
actually
does uh does it in a significantly
better way
than uh the way it was done before
because now instead of
pruning bottom up with different rules
we actually create the entire step
stack top down and from the pairwise
rule we can actually infer
how to prune things more efficiently how
to accelerate the retrieval of actual
top scoring results and so on
so a lot of different parts in the stack
had to be reinvented and re-implemented
but we know now that we can actually
increase recall and
increase the quality of the returns and
results
uh based on the pairwise scoring and
building on our stack and
for the vast majority of applications we
can actually improve performance as well
in terms of
uh in terms of slas for service for uh
retrieval so better throughput lower
latency
right
not only that because we do everything
in an automated way and we actually
learn everything
the system actually learns how to
optimally serve those models
if it actually created a much simpler
solution as well so if we try to create
this like birth
you know transform text with birth and
then search through it
then uh you get a much uh
then you can do this now on hypercube
with literally
this code so i i sweep under the rug
with this like load function i sweep
under the rug
uh some you know loading of the xml of
you know the wikipedia dump and parsing
it
all sorts of nonsense that has uh well
it's significant in terms in the sense
that it's
important to get to write okay so if
you're trying to do this on
uh with hypercube now uh now then
what you will do is literally create a
collection
of documents uh up i mean with our
client so you
instantiate the client you create a
collection that already shuffles the
data and
serializes it and puts it on your
service remote distributed service
it already uh you create an index for it
which you would now
do all the transformations pack
everything into efficient retrievals
prune everything understand how to work
with your
data and understand how to serve it uh
quickly
and then you create an endpoint which
gives you a fully distributed
uh region replicated full tolerant
you know elastic uh framework
environment where you can now uh
you can now run queries against and so
you can now run
queries directly by importing the client
from anywhere this could be in the same
notebook or anywhere else in the world
and literally hitting this end point
with with uh
with uh queries and getting back the top
results
so this is literally the entire code
needed for for that which
you can uh you can understand is
obviously
significantly simpler than the year you
know at least a year of development that
you would need to go through before
uh we recently published a paper with
home depot
actually didn't publish it was just
approved for publication was
accepted for rexis 2020
where we took their uh shopping
recommendation
model which is is very it's a very heavy
and complex model they trained in-house
uh showed how to you know the paper
actually goes through mostly about how
to train it and what
uh they have gone through creating it
but also how we went together
to production how we got it uh
to be customer facing and showing uh
actual results on the
on the home depot website which already
gives
uh now like increased conversion rate
and
revenue recommendation a significant uh
boost
so that was that was a big achievement
both for them and and of course
for us and we're very happy for them uh
and so the key takeaways are really that
uh data deep learning is really unifying
a lot of different problems and a lot of
different domains specifically in
retrieval and search and ranking
uh those uh present really hard
conceptual and engineering questions
that we are working on solving and
making some headway on
there is still a ton to be understood
and built and created
we are not nearly done uh but we've
made some progress and we're very
excited about it
[Music]